two main factors the first one is the UK
business market was much stronger than
expected so we're really pleased with
that and across all sectors and also the
return of the North American market
which didn't really come to Europe last
year as much as usual but I guess the
week's turning and ties them to come and
visit Europe and have you been pushing
Eurostar quite aggressively to the US
market at the moment
yeah we're advertising over there we've
just launched our new website we are
it's a big market for us Anna Dorothy's
working very well so fingers fingers
cross for the rest of the year I clearly
during the last few months sterling has
recovered somewhat against the euro has
that put a spring in the step of British
travellers again it's a there are
different dynamics there at work because
for even if there is a weaker pound
compared to the euro say do you care
traveler first of all people want to
protect the holidays and then maybe
instead of going to the other row to New
York for four days well they will go to
Paris for four days so we haven't seen
any weakening of demand on the UK side
on the contrary it's quite a good market
at the moment may bank holiday was very
busy and we didn't I mean it's very very
positive so hopefully this summer would
be good what's really interesting is
that you think what a pickup in business
travel to Brussels is that British
businessman trying to get a position in
order had a brexit it might be a mixture
of everything I think in general the
economy still there's confidence in the
UK but also the French market is doing
very well the economy is recovering
quite quickly so I think there are
exchanges between the two cities that
they're always very very very good what
was your reaction to the French election
I'm very happy very happy I think
Emmanuel micro is a very good president
he had a he has a strong mandate with a
66% of the votes and it was a loom
campaign so it was nice to have it come
to a close and I his pro-business he's
optimistic he's got a good views about
what he wants to do so hopefully to be
good for friends and hence for the UK
and Europe and so a strong recovery in
French GDP growth would really be quite
meaningful for your
start spottin line then it's always good
we prefer to have a to rely on strong
economies and it's it would mean a lot
to us and actually at the moment we see
both the London economy and the Paris
economy are doing very well and we can
see that in our numbers now one of the
big events view this year is going to be
direct routes between London and
Amsterdam you're any nearer to
announcing when you're going to launch
those yeah yeah we are nearer that we
caught that exactly it will be before
the end of the year but we have a first
step which is we're going to launch our
new trains on the to go to Brussels from
London in a couple of weeks so that's a
big event we've invested a lot of money
into the Brussels station to welcome our
trains Anna and then the step after we'd
be Amsterdam and Rotterdam and we're
very excited
I'm also the market share do you think
you can capture in fairly short order oh
it's a I would say stable in terms of
market share it's very competitive at
the moment but on the Amsterdam route we
would expect to gain market share of
course against the airline so that's how
I where to grow theta way I think what
we'll do is where it will grow the
market we take some share from the
airlines but what we know from
experience that a lot of people will say
oh there's your star I'm going to try it
and so we hope to grow the market